hi I'm Erik Bosse the Captain Marvel
wait holy crap there's a new ventures
endgame trailer marvel it's not wasting
any time with this hype Captain Marvel
and Thor are buds now Stark is back on
earth and they got new armor Hawkeye is
hurt yeah we don't know how much of this
footage will actually be in the movie
and much of this is old footage from
past MCU moments but do you pay close
attention to the way this is all being
presented there could be some major
clues for end games you know the drill
I'm gonna break it all down frame by
Fleur can frame for all the microscopic
details that you might have missed and
spoiler warning because basing things on
Captain Marvel my speculation has been
weirdly on target lately so I might ruin
lives let's get started
cassie was like a thousand years ago I
fought my way out of that cave became
Iron Man okay the trailer opens by
flashing back to the scene in the first
Ironman after Tony Stark escaped from
the ten rings terrorist group in
Afghanistan engineering DIY armor and an
arc reactor from a box of scraps Stark's
voiceover says the memory feels like a
thousand years ago and I imagine it's on
his mind because he's in the parallel
situation now stranded on the
guardianship the Bennett are forced to
engineer way home with the new box of
scraps which I assume will be his
nickname for nebula now in this trailer
notice how all the footage from past
Marvel movies is in black and white with
just hints of the color red a Super Bowl
trailer used a similar Schindler's listy
color grading as a way to visually link
the Fallen Avengers with the Marvel
Studios 10 title logo the monochromatic
colors reflect the grey dust with the
color red of okie in the blood that was
spilt in these deaths and you may
remember dust and blood as imagery that
was foreshadowed by Black Panther and
infinity war Thanos would have nothing
but dust and naught and dust the blood
is exactly what Thanos wanted way to
jinx it to chawla some are also saying
the color red could be connected to the
reality stone I don't know why the
reality stone will be that much more
important in this final movie than the
other five stones but the row thread
rumor has it these in-game trailers are
being deliberately withholding with
Marblehead Kevin Feige suggesting that
the marketing will only show stuff from
the first 15 minutes of the movie which
was last reported to be around 3 hours
long and other reports that the
directors the Rousseau's have only
allowed 8 minutes of footage to be used
for promotional purposes necessitating
trailers to tie-in footage from old
movies but as we dig deeper into this we
will see how these past memories might
contain a hidden meaning that unlocks
the truth of this movie story so let's
keep watching
we lost I loved you
analysts said no more surprises but I
was really hoping to pull off one last
one okay here there's iron man's helmet
suggesting Starks words here are part of
his recording - Pepper Potts that we saw
in the first trailer and like how the
editing here syncs up this moment with
the shot of pepper holding Starks helmet
and Iron Man 3 because remember in that
scene Pepper's similarly worried that
Tony was dead but this helmet contained
a hidden voice recording from Tony here
an in-game Tony's doing the exact same
thing maybe in case this helmet ever
gets recovered hoping pepper will
remember that moment in Iron Man 3 and
received this goodbye apology from him
or maybe since that moment Iron Man 3
involves pepper putting on the helmet
herself this could be a signal of how
Tony Stark will get rescued remember
there were those choice words that Tony
used in the first trailer just directed
being adrift in space with zero promise
of rescue is more fun that sounds and
some leaked wardrobe images of Gwyneth
Paltrow hinted that we could see pepper
donning armor that Tony designed for her
for a situation just like this which
allowed pepper to become her rescue
character from the comics and
potentially come save Tony there's also
this other shot from the first Ironman
of the encased arc reactor that pepper
gave Tony a joke about his tinman
heartlessness peppers gift would go on
to save Tony's life after Obadiah Stane
paralyzed him and yanked out his second
parks of scraps from hand of his chest
Tony's voice over here says I know we
said no more surprises but I was really
hoping to pull off one last one he's
recalling the moment with pepper and the
beginning of infinity war and we should
have no more surprises
ever I should promise you yes I will
before we move on we see this shot of
stark gazing out through the cockpit of
the Benatar the shot was in the first
trailer as well but some details have
been updated whatever that cosmic body
is that they're facing previously had a
dim pinkish tone now it's much brighter
with a double blue flare slowly tense
reflect enough to hold the ship only
stark remains in that pinkish light now
maybe this means nothing trailers do
tend to play around with the coloring
the lighting to fit the tone of whatever
trailer it's in but this lens flare to
me indicates that Stark and nebula are
facing something specific a planet a
star another ship someone flying through
space to see them something because we
do see at the end
this trailer these two do end up back on
earth and whatever they're facing could
be a step on that process let's move on
none of us go by
we can do is okay in this section we're
reminded of the origin of Captain
America Steve Rogers from his first
movie at the recruitment center there's
the iconic shot of Steve before
receiving Super Soldier Serum seeing his
reflection not tall enough to line up
with this it could be you recruitment
poster and I actually just realized that
spider-man and the spider-verse totally
borrowed the shot anyway there's some
other footage that we saw in the super
old trailer Liberty island surrounded by
boats perhaps boats that have either
washed up from the dusted cruise after
the snap or boats of search party crews
looking for missing people out on the
open waters and then a shot of caps it
and group therapy perhaps reflecting how
Sam needs to run therapy sessions for
veterans in Winter Soldier the voiceover
we're hearing is from the character
Peggy Carter is when Steve met with her
and Captain America Winter Soldier all
we can do is our best and sometimes the
best we can do you read into Peggy's
words here because we read into
everything I'm sure this whole idea of
going back stands out to you right since
many of us have speculated that going
back in time could be part of the plot
of endgame but based off this quote I
don't know because Peggy says none of us
can go back but she does say to start
over which does imply some kind of reset
ain't another way that you can reset
rather than going back in time could be
to hop sideways in an alternate timeline
within a multiverse and start over
perhaps the way c-137 Rick and Morty's
started over by replacing versions
themselves who died before I go deeper
in this insanity we see Hawkeye clint
barton at his family farm where nothing
will ever go wrong he's teaching archery
to his daughter Lyla maybe they're
starting to adapt his daughter into the
Cape Bishop storyline with Hawkeye is a
mentor figure looking to pass the torch
viola is older than we last saw her in
age of Ultron which makes sense that was
a few years before infinity war and you
can see his wife Laura at the picnic
table the background and his son Cooper
who also looks older and their youngest
Nathaniel who's no longer baby but I
noticed Clint's hair he doesn't yet look
like he got a haircut from the Barbara
Anza car we're probably looking at a pre
snap memory before tragedy strikes like
maybe after this high five Clint will
look at his hand and see dust on it
dust from Lila's
and and then Clint turns in horror to
see Laura and Cooper and Nathaniel
fading to piles do worse picnic ever if
you like sad Hawkeye there's more of it
in the next clip
mr. sofa
okay in this section there's Hawkeye in
the rain in Tokyo we saw this in the
first trailer Sternin to face Black
Widow now in the past we speculated the
movie could be adapting the Ronin
version of the character from the comics
in which Clint takes on a Japanese lone
warrior storyline the closeup of these
two holding hands carries a lot of
emotion and if I'm right about that
footage with his family this could be
the first hand that Hawkeye touched his
affectionately since his daughters
there's a quick shot of cap as a
pallbearer at Peggy Carter's funeral we
saw that in Captain America Civil War
and then we move on to some flashback
shots of Asgard in the first Thor movie
with Thor after redeeming himself in
returning Asgard the end of the movie
talking with his father Odin I should
make you proud you've already made me
proud it's fitting that as garden Odin
appear in these black-and-white
flashbacks because remember Thor
recently watched both of these things
die in Ragnarok arguably it was the
absence of Odin and Asgard that opened
the door for the final stages of Dana's
conquests let's move on
I saw all these people die
I keep telling everybody they should
move on
okay here we return to the final moments
of infinity war with Thor kicking
himself after not going forth a nose his
head he talks about seeing Falcon Black
Panther Scarlet Witch and Bucky fading
into dust and Wakanda now it's
interesting to rewatch this whole death
montage because you can see little
variations in the way each avenger lets
go like Wanda throws her head back and
gives in to the inevitable because he
could say her soul already kind of died
with vision
whereas with Falcon Anthony Mackie said
the Russos side coached him with some
choice words to get the reaction they
needed we were on set and I'm laying
down in the mud and it's cold and a
director goes yeah the Russo brothers
are like you're you're you're
disintegrating to think about your
leaving earth what would you say and I'm
like cap does meaning earth could imply
a transference to some other realm for
the snap victims like the quantum realm
or maybe that soul dimension that Gamora
went to as opposed to just like pure
oblivion I dig deeper into this and
another video go check that out there's
actually one more interesting change
that they made to this footage they
don't want to point out but first I want
to make better help for sponsoring this
video
better help as an affordable online
private service that connects you with a
personalized therapist or counselor
look I know fans like the joke about
feeling super depressed while watching
the deaths of Infinity Ward what life
like real life can really build up on
you sometimes like I know stress has
gotten the best of me and my job and
that's why a service like better help
was super helpful for me when I tried it
out better help connects you with a
licensed professional counselor caring
professionals specializing in the issues
you want to talk about you can get help
on your own time and at your own
convenience with secure video chats or
text chats phone sessions whichever
option is easiest for you and you can
start talking with someone who's right
for you in under 24 hours in a process
that's hassle free and affordable now to
be clear this is proactive mental health
it's not a crisis line and I'm not
pushing therapy on you if you don't
think it's right for you better hope has
actually been really good about
listening to user feedback and making
necessary updates but if you're 18 years
or older and if you want to give this a
try
you can get 10% off your first month
that better help calm slash new rock
stars or go to their website and when
you log in use our discount code new
rock stars
okay back to this footage from infinity
war notice how the color grading
rendered caps gloves to be
read despite the fact that in the
original movie they weren't read they
were actually brown they didn't just
highlight the red that was in the
original footage they changed the color
in a way this suggests caps guilt over
this loss the blood on his hands now and
this footage cap says he keeps telling
everyone to move on so let's do that
some dude on us
there's a small chance
we owe this
everyone who's not in this room to try
this clip cap chats with Natasha about
his refusal to move on
and notice Natasha's hair it's longer
and that blonde color has grown out
almost with her natural red retaking
black widow's hair changes throughout
the footage we've seen / in-game she
said the shorter blonde hair that she
had an infinity war and she also has
this hot mess tied in a neat braid I
think all of this is to show a passage
of time and maybe several stages of the
Avengers comeback against Thanos that
aren't part of one big smart mission
like it appears that when Carol Danvers
comes back it's not like they're gonna
spring into the final conflict this is
gonna happen in thesis there's also a
quick shot of Ruffalo doing his best not
to spoil the ending of the movie but
look behind Bruce Banner here there's a
weapon leaning against the wall some
have described it as Corvus glaive
glaive or perhaps Loki's sceptre but I'm
pretty sure this is Clint's new bow
confirming the presence of Clint Burton
in this scene then there's this shot a
Scott Lang looking very confused tez he
passes a pole that's plastered with
missing posters one of them says Tony P
Henderson which from what I can tell is
not connected to the Marvel in any way
but I'm sure Tony P Henderson will be
instrumental to defeating Thanos this
whole neighborhood is very Walking Dead
first episode post-apocalyptic weeds
overtaking the lawn in a driveway and
moped covered in leaves and people's ass
probably it's a shame that it looks like
Scott's gonna be driving his security
company van because I would have loved
to see Scott ride up on that thing to
greet the others the way Bruce Banner
rolled up in the first Avengers another
post-apocalyptic reference point that it
brought up before is the HBO of series
of leftovers which deals with the
aftermath of a rapture style event with
two percent of the world's population
having vanished one of the interesting
consequences of that world is the fact
that when some people went poof their
dogs went nuts and it caused all those
dogs to find other dogs and form these
roaming packs throughout neighborhoods
to attack people and notice here behind
Scott on that porch that looks like a
dog so Scott should watch out or maybe
it's a dog statue but he should still
watch out because behind that statue
hide him very still in plain sight mr.
axe I know it looks like nothing the
guy's pretty sneaky I also like how the
editing SIG's Black Widow saying even if
there's a small chance or the shot of
ant-man could be a hint that their
mission involves his technology
more on that a bit now let's see a shot
of the new Quinn jet as it arrives over
Tokyo I was wondering what city that was
but that is Tokyo's Rainbow Bridge there
and notice how about half of the
buildings of the city appear to have
their lights off so like New York every
world city is feeling the pain of half
its people dusting away now this
probably the scene where Black Widow is
going looking for Hawkeye and we do see
them in the next shot on board a ship
but this isn't the Quinn jet this is
actually the guardianship the Benatar so
this looks like some confirmation that
the way Tony Stark and nebula will
return to earth is on board the Benatar
recently footage from in game which
shown to Disney shareholders at a closed
meeting because Disney shareholders are
richer and better people than us and
they're taking over the world and some
of it included several of these
characters on board the ship with rocket
piloting warning them all against puking
on a ship and Captain Marvel was sitting
shotgun in this footage
perhaps so these characters are on their
way to Titan to the planet Thanos
settled on and they're intending to
confront him let's move on to the next
foot
[Music]
whatever it takes
air intakes okay here we see Hawkeye
running down this tunnel with red lights
as an explosion rips through it this
looks like the same location that we saw
him in in the Superbowl trailer with the
same red light notice this flashlight on
his wrist in the later shot you can see
that he rigged it so that he can aim the
light in the direction that he has his
arrow not then kind of like a mounted
light on a gun very cool and then we see
my favorite pairing of this trailer
rocket and war machine rocket as I
pointed out in a Super Bowl trailer
breakdown wears a new suit this is the
blue jumpsuit that he wears in the
guardians of the galaxy comics but also
roadies rocking a new suit this armor is
way bulkier even more than the war
machine armor that he has on when he
suits up beside Scott and then other
footage we could be looking at the
rumored War destroyer armor that I've
heard about or maybe the war machine
Buster armor that appeared in Lego form
there are also some shots of cap and
Hawkeye Avengers HQ and then look at
this frame was Scott here behind him on
that lamp in the light on the awning
outside some other light source behind
the column it all begins to glow
brighter and brighter can actually see
some of that glow starting to reflect
from Scott shoulder where is this light
coming from maybe he's Scott's looking
at Carol Danvers glowing as she starts
to go binary and it's like triggering
other appliances could be for returning
and doing the same thing or maybe we're
looking at Avengers HQ under attack from
some threat which is why they would have
to suit up and then we see this
interesting shot of Thor he's bearing
Stormbreaker as electricity shoots off
and looks awesome maybe it's just me but
doesn't this look a lot like his arrival
in Wakanda and Avengers infinity war
like storm raker here looks especially
supercharged the exact same way it
wasn't that battle of course the angle
is different and Thor's expression has
changed like noticed how he looks down
at Stormbreaker a bit unsure of himself
almost like how did I get here maybe
what we're looking at is Thor reliving
this memory of the Battle of acondo a
different form of time travel or
alternate timeline hopping in which the
Avengers can in Peggy Carter's words
start over and replay past fights but
this time make different choices in
Thor's case I can't imagine a redo he'd
want more than this battle where this
time he could aim for the head maybe
something similar is going on with
nebula in this next shot it's hard to
tell where she is but all that smoky
rubble looks a lot like the
one's of Titan after she crashed her
ship into Thanos confronted him Titan
was definitely a lot redder in color and
she does have two batons here not one
but still could we be seen nebula
reliving this moment where this time
maybe she would decide not to tell Peter
quill that Thanos killed Gamora and she
would try to prevent quill from hitting
Thanos in the face and breaking him out
of his trance so they could get the
gauntlet off there is a rumor that Tony
Stark's barf memory technology could
play a role in endgame maybe all the
Avengers could be reflecting back on
past memories like this battles that
felt like a thousand years ago within
able to somehow displace their
consciousnesses to past moments and make
new choices in those moments just try to
pretend like that isn't totally insane
as we move on to the next clip
[Music]
whatever it takes in this section
Natasha almost raged on the firing range
of Avengers HQ somehow hearing the
trailer music in her head and firing the
gun perfectly in sync with the rhythm
and then we get more of this shot of cap
tightening the straps of his shield this
being the first time he gets it back
since dueling with Tony Stark and Civil
War along with this close-up of his
dirty face but perfectly white teeth cap
is wearing his previous generation suit
before the darker maskless version that
he wore in Infinity Ward this could be
more evidence that these Avengers will
in some way have to return to past
versions of themselves
it looks like cap is on the same
battlefield that rock and war machine
Iran and the nebulas on the smoke and
the color temperature of these three
shots all match that horizon line behind
cap looks vaguely similar to the hills
that surround Thanos his farmhouse on
Titan - and there's something purple
behind cap real question is how thick is
it maybe the Avengers hunted Thanos down
to his new home lit the place up
oh my corn but even if they do I just
doubt that this would be enough to fix
anything like maybe the Avengers will
make a brave effort to avenge in the
opening acts of the movie but fail again
requiring them to violate the laws of
physics and some crazy way to undo the
snap but next we get this awesome shot
of ant-man shrunken down pole vaulting
with this pencil passing a headphone
jack and what looks like a roll of tape
and a huge deluge of water now it's a
bit hard to tell where he is but I think
Scott could be on the desk in Avengers
HQ and that shot of him and Rhodey
these are all just supplies that would
be on that desk and that water could be
point out of one of those mugs is it
tips over but there's a lot of crazy
crap going on here again we could be
looking at some attack on Avengers HQ
perhaps whatever efforts the Avengers
made against Thanos will lead danos to
striking back at them at home but the
next section contains the biggest
bombshells of the trailer so let's watch
it
[Music]
[Music]
okay so here we see the Avengers walking
through HQ including Tony Stark and
nebula returned safely from Titan they
join cap and Scott and Hawkeye Rhodey
and Natasha big thing to point out here
they're all wearing this new white
colored armor now we have seen this
armor teased and toys and merchandise
for the movie and concept art and some
people are describing it as quantum
Armour maybe because it resembles the
quantum suit that Hank Pym wore when he
ventured down into the quantum realm and
ant-man the wasp
notice how Rody's armor is larger and
bulkier whatever tech they're wearing
must have been applied to his war
machine armor meanwhile Stark has sleek
nanotech armor that probably would just
work underneath the suit but there's
definitely good chance at this armors
quantum realm connected because we know
the quantum realm will play some
important role in endgame Tom Holland
said that Benedict cumberpatch would
have to mention quantum realm and a lot
of his lines and ingame and ant-man the
wasp sees the existence of time vortexes
and the possibility of phase shifting
into parallel realities in the quantum
level so I am assuming that the Avengers
are wearing these suits as they set off
to explore this kind of quantum infinity
and maybe in a way that taps into their
memories as a form of timeline Medlin
because another detail to point out here
the color scheme of these suits is black
and white and red not all over just a
little under that matches the color
scheme of those past footage clips
throughout this trailer now some of you
are looking at these shots and saying
hey we got proof that is actually stark
and nebula who are digitally erased from
that earlier group March shot in the
past trailer panel thinks so that shot
also contained Thor and Natasha's hair
was shorter in it I just don't think we
can put these two marches side-by-side
and say they're definitely the same
moment like we also can't see Thor or
banner slash Hulk or Captain Marvel or
rocket in any of these frames maybe
they're out of frame or maybe they're on
a side mission and again it's just hard
to take all of this footage that
literally because this could end up
being like that group joggin shot and
the trailer for infinity war that got
used as a basis for a ton of theories
that ended up being not in the final
movie at all Marvel has the power to d-h
samuel l.jackson they can deep fake
everything so let's move on to the final
clip
I like this one
okay as we learn in the post-credits
scene for Captain Marvel Carol Danvers
does join up with the Avengers in HQ not
long after the snap though it looks like
here she's definitely changed out of
that new upgraded suit of hers I love
how she does not flinch at all when Thor
summons Stormbreaker
whizzes past her really all that happens
is her hair just waves a bit and she's
still not afraid to stare him down kind
of like you try that again we're gonna
have issues and as we've seen with Hulk
with Valkyrie
Thor's best friends are always the ones
that could beat the crap out of them so
my question for you is which pairing are
you most excited to see an endgame
rocket war machine Hawkeye and Black
Widow
Thor and Captain Marvel Earth's Tarkin
cap it's about time these two talked
again comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on twitter and
instagram at a vas and subscribe to this
channel for more Marvel breakdowns and
theories and if you happen to live in
the LA area come check out my live nerdy
comedy show darkest timeline it's every
first Friday of the month at the Acme
theater in North Hollywood
our next shows on April 5th we got some
surprise guests gonna be a lot of fun
thank you for watching and the Avengers
can chant whatever it takes as much as
they want but we know what it's gonna
take to beat danos off lurkin just put
goose in front of Thanos and he'll lose
a lot more than an eye
[Music]